Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again. We're going to talk about head and neck cancers, the common cancers that we see in the head of the neck area.
We're talking nasopharyngeal, the throat cancers, thyroid cancers, salivary gland cancers, actually several of them.
Squamous cell cancers, that's the cell type that lines these tissues, bronchial cancers, oral cancers.
They're really named after the cell type, so there are some abdominal carcinomas in this classification, many of them are squamous cell cancers.
And they're named after the specific location, so where it is in the body, that's where the naming system comes from.
And then they're graded and there's multiple different subtypes for each one, so they do get kind of confusing.
From a natural perspective, really, what we're looking for, less the diagnosis, is what exactly is going to work for that cancer.
To know that we do the testing, so we test with a cheek swab with genetic testing, so that we can hold it on what is going to be the best nutraceuticals, what is going to be the best diet,
what is going to be the best frequencies to use with the right frequency technology as well.
And that's where we can get real specific and have the best results possible.
One of the biggest things that we encounter is people think that they have to choose between natural care and conventional care, and that's just not true.
Most of our patients have done some sort of conventional care, some are still doing conventional care.
Many of them failed conventional care, so now they're turning to alternative, and quite honestly I wish they would have started with alternative care, at least concurrently with the standards of care that is out there, because I think you're just going to have much better results.
Alternative care and conventional care are not at odds with one another, so you can do them at the same time, and you're going to just have much better results.
If you're going to choose conventional care with the damage that that can do to your body, you definitely want to be doing a lot of alternative things to help build up your cells and to build up your immune system, it's really key.
But when you do choose to do a natural approach, it does get kind of confusing. I tell people it's kind of like drinking from a fire hose.
You got all sorts of people that are telling you different things to do, and the more you read, the more confusing it can be, and you can feel like should I be taking you know 100 different supplements.
The answer is absolutely not, you do not want to do that more can be can be worse, so less is more when it comes to cancer care.
So we want to hold it and be specific on what specific nutraceuticals are going to be best for you, what specific diet is going to be best for you.
We don't want you to take everything out of your diet to take all your joy away, we want to be specific to test for the fuel sources.
We want to be specific to test for the right frequencies, everything natural that we can do, and we do that through the cheek swab.
So that's how we get started. We ultimately want you to have the best results possible. So whether you choose to do conventional care or not, that's your choice.
But certainly adding alternative care is going to add years to your life, and really a lot of life to your years, that quality of life is so key important.
Ultimately, we want you to have the best success possible, that's what we're going to be hoping for and praying for for you.
So regardless of whether you choose care in our clinic or not, please download all my books, look at my site, go on our YouTube channel, everything is for free, so we can't give away any more information than we do.
So we're constantly adding to it, so always come back, and no, regardless of what you choose, we will be praying for you, so that's a promise.
Thank you.